la mia adolescenza ha fatto schifo
lo dico veramente
e mi manca il telecomando per le slide
che è la cosa più bella in assoluto
quindi se me lo portate vi fate un vero
piacere
perché ero timido introverso
grassottello e se vogliamo ancora
mettere più carne al fuoco anche goffo
mi hanno deriso sia compagni e
professori
ve l'ho detto ero rotondetto adesso vi
faccio anche vedere
il bello della diretta
[Applauso]
alle medie pensate il prof di educazione
fisica in palestra e alla mia scarsa
voglia di allenarmi ha detto palmi
ma ti sei mangiato troppo i panettoni da
oggi ti chiamerò panettone
quell'appellativo mi ha inseguito per un
po devo dire la verità almeno fino alle
superiori quando poi effettivamente ho
cambiato scorte
vabè nick le cose saranno sicuramente
andate meglio beh sì e no c'erano giorni
buoni e giorni cattivi e incollate dal
fatto che non sono mai stato una cima
nello studio almeno fino all'università
quando ho capito che potevo studiare per
me e non dovevo studiare per gli altri e
avrete anche lì qualche problema per
esempio e vi giuro è l'ultimo la mia
prof di chimica ok a alla mia
probabilmente ennesima richiesta di
spiegazione delle formule mi ha detto
davanti a tutta la classe e urlando
palmieri sparati alle vene
risate fragorose da parte di tutti ho
avuto qualche qualche bel po di
risentimento
però poi a quell'età me l'insicurezza
mangiava vivo quindi zitto e al posto la
ciliegina sulla torta era che avevo
mille idee e tutte poco chiare unite
tutte queste cose ad un ragazzo con
pochi brufoli almeno quello
e otterrete un tragicomico nicola
palmieri quindi credetemi quando vi dico
che la mia adolescenza ha fatto schifo
ma dai mille calci in culo della vita
ott rinforzi vocati e non ti rialzi
facilmente una volta mi hanno chiesto ma
tu rifaresti tutto da capo
io le ho guardate i dritti negli occhi
ha detto col cavolo col cavolo mi hanno
detto di non essere troppo volgare
quindi
tornare adolescente senza sapere quello
che so oggi mi spaventa a morte
cioè
mi spaventa come all'epoca mi spaventava
parlare con le ragazze mi bloccavo
era difficilissimo
stavo lì fermo immobile ero talmente
timido che quando parlavo con una
ragazza che mi piaceva cioè stavo lì
fermo è piuttosto che parlarle me la
sognavo la notte preferito
eppure sarebbe bastato solo un ciao
detto magari a
mezza bocca no un po più un po più pieno
una spintarella in più
ecco questo mi rendeva triste il non
potermi esprimere come avrei voluto
mi annientava e tutta quella tristezza
che avevo la sfogavo in una cosa le
poesie
era un poeta un poeta
maledetto
pensavo
poi qualche anno fa ho riletto quello
che ho scritte mazza che me
mazza che pupo
funziona bene ma la volgarità a ben
guardare 20 anni più tardi il mio era un
problema di comunicazione
non avevo gli strumenti adatti
anzi non avevo lo strumento perché poi
come una grande luce in fondo al tunnel
è arrivato lui il cellulare no non lo
smart phone
il cellulare
ma finalmente potevo comunicare
scrivendo gli sms quelli che oggi si
usano solo per ricevere i codici di
accesso alle banche per intenderci
scherzi a parte gli sms mi hanno salvato
da una vita di solitudine perché avevo
uno strumento in mano che mi permetteva
di comunicare e soprattutto di
agganciare qualche ragazzo
insomma se ho dato il mio primo vero
bacio lo devo a gli sms
ragazzi e ragazze anche se non vi vedo
tutti io voglio dirmelo voi siete
coraggiosi perché crescere è spaventoso
è terrificante
perché non si possiedono gli strumenti
giusti per capire quello che ci accade
per non parlare poi degli ormoni qua mi
riferisco soprattutto ai maschietti e
terrificante perché ogni cosa brutta che
accade sembra catastrofica e risolvibile
invece voi siete coraggiosi perché ogni
giorno dovete parlare con qualcuno che
forse non capisce il dramma che magari
in quel momento state provando che si è
dimenticato di quanto a giorni alterni
possa fare schifo l'adolescenza ma vi
assicuro che poi
arrivati un po più avanti nel percorso
vi ricorderete delle risate degli odori
delle emozioni e lecite
e forse vi ricorderete anche dei pianti
delle offese e di quanto in effetti poi
non vi abbiano capito poi troppo ecco
tuttavia questo vi aiuterà a creare i
vostri attrezzi del mestiere quelli che
oggi magari vi mancano gli strumenti che
poi utilizzerete per andare avanti nel
percorso della vita e allora da ex
adolescente fallito
voglio dirvi questo e devi questa fase
che avrei tanto voluto sentirmi dire io
sei coraggioso 6 coraggiosa e qualsiasi
cosa che accadrà ci servirà per arrivare
ad essere la splendida persona che saia
ci
priva money un periodo almeno
tecnologicamente
in cui abbiamo tutto nelle nostre mani
in vent'anni siamo andati avanti su
tutti i fronti tecnologici e abbiamo
vissuto talmente tante di quelle piccole
rivoluzioni in ambito comunicazione sono
dimenticate contesa ecco la tecnologia
ha plasmato
letteralmente il mio modo di comunicare
e oggi è parte integrante del mio lavoro
e anche se non ce ne accorgiamo con
sciame consciamente tutti ci ha
effettivamente
plasmati nel bene e nel male ho fatto
l'esempio di 20 anni fa perché sono
passati solo 20 anni
ora il concetto di tempo è strano perché
quando ai 15 anni
i 18 sembrano non arrivare mai e 20 anni
ti sembra un lasso di tempo eterno ma
quando hai 40 la percezione cambia e 20
anni non ti sembrano poi molti
voglio sottolineare una cosa che
probabilmente si farà incazzare io sono
qui a parlare ad una platea di ragazzi
di circa 18 anni e mi sento un po straw
cattivello
a dirlo ma vivere in un periodo pieno di
possibilità
potete accedere a tutta l'informazione
che volete
ed è al 90 per cento gratuita potrebbe
raggiungere ogni obiettivo grazie alla
comunicazione perché oggi potete essere
virtualmente ovunque
guardatevi intorno
vivete in un mondo in cui si può fare
davvero tutto bisogna avere due cose la
voglia e la curiosità
ora dopo tutto questo chiacchierare
questo parlare voglio lasciarvi qualche
consiglio soprattutto per il futuro
lavorativo
comunicazione nei prossimi 20 anni le
cose cambieranno ancora quello che
credevate impossibile diventerà
possibile
e io non so se sarà la realtà virtuale
la realtà aumentata
gli ologrammi ecco ma cambierà tutto di
nuovo quindi dovete fare una cosa dovete
essere i primi ad adattarvi perché chi
si adatta per primo poi guadagna anche
di più
state parlando
con un ragazzo una volta
che giocava sul commodore 64 io lo so
che magari voi non sapete nemmeno che
cos'è un commodore 64
vi basti sapere che io avevo un monitor
è grande più o meno quanto un ipad che
aveva 16 colori vabbè 16 colori da ci
fai un sacco di cose con 16 colori ecco
i miei sedici colori erano 16 colori
tutti uguali perché non sfumature di
arancione i pixel grandi così quindi io
dovevo veramente far fatica per capire
quali erano i personaggi che stavo
vedendo questo per dirvi che poche
settimane fa ho visto
la tech demo di un motore grafico il
nuovo su uno schermo 4k e ho fatto
davvero difficoltà a capire che quella
fosse una realtà inventata
quindi preparatevi a quello che arriverà
fra 20 anni
2 lingua non è banale ma le persone che
vengono da me in azienda l'inglese non
lo sanno poi molto eppure l'inglese
serve a tanto anche con i linguaggi di
programmazione quindi studiate l'inglese
perché sarà indispensabile e ve lo dice
uno che sia una grande comprensione
dell'inglese merito delle serie tv in
lingua ma quando deve parlare deve fare
cose importanti in inglese chiamato
qualcun altro ok onestà prima di tutto e
poi l'avete capitano il mondo va verso
la tecnologia e tutti quanti dispositivi
che abbiamo sono stampato una cosa di
made in china o per quelli come me è
made in china non capiscono ben inglese
ecco questo per dirvi che serviranno
delle figure di mezzo le persone che
parlano anche del cinese quindi
fateci un pensiero 3 blob chain ebbene
dopo che c'entra block chain beh a
bruxelles si basa su protocolli di
comunicazione che qualcuno deve
programmare quindi se avete solo
sommariamente sentito questo termine da
domani approfondite l'argomento
oggi si sente parlare di blog chain solo
in correlazionale cripto valute una cosa
è strana con le gritto perché ho le ami
o li odi
ecco il problema è che prima di fare una
scelta
devi documentarti perché con tutta
probabilità il 95 per cento dei progetti
in cripto domani non ci sarà più rimarrà
solo il 5 per cento
però la tecnologia rimarrà e questa
tecnologia si chiama la block chaining
ok che cos'è la brucia in due parole un
registro distribuito ora immaginate che
tutti in cui dentro abbiamo lo stesso
quaderno dove scriviamo minuto per
minuto quello che accade e poi c'è uno
furbo che decide di scrivere
qualcos'altro con una semplice ricerca
incrociata si capisce che quella
informazione è stata falsata e quindi la
brucia in che cosa c da c da un
contenuto certo
e sicuro o più stringato il concetto ma
di base non fatevi cogliere impreparati
perché la tecnologia
bruxelles il futuro ci sarà ok video ora
il video creare un video segue una
determinata grammatica e anche se a me
fanno scassare di risate scassare i
video trash che non hanno una
comunicazione perfettissima voi non fate
questo errore
studiate la grammatica video se vi piace
ovviamente fare video
oggi la comunicazione passa soprattutto
per i filmati
checché se ne dica anche su pitot c'è un
determinato tipo di comunicazione quindi
consiglio nel consiglio per diciamo
spaccare
dei social veloci fate attenzione ai
primi 3 secondi perché sono quelli che
servono per agganciare il vostro utente
2 il ritmo la gente se lo dimentica ma i
video per essere belli devono avere un
ritmo e secondo voi perché andavano
tanto bene i video musicali
perché il ritmo lo dava la canzone
3 non fate i personaggi perché se poi le
cose vi vanno bene poi dovrete avere a
vita questa cosa addosso del personaggio
e smetterete di divertirvi e poi una
cosa da da boomers anche se faccio parte
della generazione millennials fate
doppio check che significa prima di
pubblicare una cosa chiedete vi sono
effettivamente convinto di poterla
pubblicare
perché mettere facile togliere
ora
videogiochi
no non sto parlando di videogiocare
c'è un stato un boom dei videogiochi a
dirla tutta è ancora in atto questo boom
eco è spaventoso ma il mondo dei
videogiochi è cresciuto tanto una
ricerca qualche tempo fa
parlava i tre miliardi di persone
tra i miliardi di videogiocatori nel
mondo siamo circa 8 miliardi
dovete fare un po i conti con questa
cosa e io voglio parlare del creare i
videogiochi
perché se giocare sembra semplice e
intuitivo è perché qualcuno ci si è
messo e che ha creato un mondo facile da
giocare bello da giocare immersivo e non
ci si rende ancora troppo conto che è un
videogioco è il concetto di arte più
completo che esista basta rifletterci
storia modelli regia doppiaggio
programmazione sarà un design
interazione che potrei continuare ancora
nei videogiochi poi spaziare
tantissimi livelli di arte e di lavoro
in poche parole poi scegliere tu dove
specializzare
ti devi specializzare però perché le
figure specializzate spesso prendono
anche di più
ora in bestia
[Musica]
informati in vesti perché se metti da
parte 100 euro al mese fra 20 anni ti
troverai un bel gruzzoletto
ora questo gruppo ti potrà servire a
comparti né a casa oa lanciare il tuo
sogno quindi devi entrare un po
nell'ottica
soprattutto di una cosa che deve
diventare un po il tuo migliore amico
l'interesse composto che cos'è
l'interesse composto non è altro che il
reinvestimento
della percentuale guadagnata una cosa
semplicissima faccio un esempio 100 euro
al mese per vent'anni ha un interesse e
6 per cento
sono circa 50mila euro per 30 sono
100mila euro
sono 100 euro al mese però interesse
composto non te lo insegnano a scuola
quindi ripensare tu
ora
perseveranza mi faccio incazzare un po
di più da domani alzatevi mezz'ora prima
e passate un po di tempo con voi
dovete comunicare con voi stessi e
dovete allenare la vostra perseveranza
se c'è una cosa che vi servirà più
avanti nella vita
sarà proprio questa la perseveranza
nessuno nasce campione o genio ma tu
puoi raggiungere effettivamente ogni
obiettivo
se perseveri nel tempo è una cosa
fondamentale
da capire perché questo vi aiuterà anche
a parlare con voi stessi
perché poi quando andrete più avanti
nella vita
sarete troppo occupati a fare fare fare
e vi dimenticherete di parlare con voi
stessi se vi guardate intorno
tutto e comunicazione tutto ogni cosa
riesce a raccontarsi in un modo o
nell'altro
devi solo sa essere tu a scegliere se
vuoi essere chi ascolta occhi racconta e
credetemi se vi dico che se io oggi sono
qui a parlare c'è speranza per tutti
grazie
[Musica]